so a few days ago I uploaded a video
where I interviewed a bunch of
educational youtubers at VidCon after
the video went live I got some comments
saying where all the women which made me
realize wow yeah I didn't interview a
single female creator I had made it
really easy for guys to be part of the
video but I didn't realize that maybe it
wouldn't be as easy or comfortable or
obvious for women to say yes even if the
invitation was technically open to
everyone so with only a few hours left
before my flight I headed to the
convention center with my camera popped
into a creator Meetup and asked a few of
my favorite creators in person everyone
I asked said yes and they were all super
excited to contribute here's what they
had to say
[Music]
I would tell myself to embrace the bride
but you never know what's going to
happen next I feel as VidCon for example
I have met so many incredible people and
each year it's changed a little bit the
direction I've been going in but that
had sentence in a bad thing I've been
exploring new ideas and I really like
evolved my channel has evolved and I
have evolved because I'm just kind of
like taking the ride and following the
where everything goes the advice I would
give myself is probably the one that I
took which is don't be afraid to try new
things even if you're not good at them
you get a lot
if you're not worrying about how you
perform and you simply enjoy
I would say value your time I think a
lot of the time people think that they
should do an estate to get ahead
whatever it takes but your time is also
extremely valuable and kind of a form of
currency so first to go back five years
I would be just starting out at
university so my advice would be to not
worry about too much what your major is
going to be major or take courses of
anything that interest you and
eventually those interest will sort of
give you a career give your future
directions you don't need to know
exactly you know what job you're going
to get in five years time I'm still like
working in a space now that I didn't
really know about five years ago so just
do what interests you
[Music]
I am a big believer of checking in with
my younger self to see what advice she
would give me what would ten-year-old
Katelyn think of that situation what
would fifteen-year-old Kaitlyn think of
this situation
younger Kaylee didn't know a lot of
things but what she did know was she was
really passionate about and really
confident about me so I always try to
check in with my younger self in terms
of giving my younger self advice I think
that I would just tell her to keep doing
what she's doing and keep trusting her
gut if I trust myself and I'm just
really honest - nope no playing games
and I'm just like this is what I'm about
what are you about what are you actually
after I can read the situation and then
make really cool things because that's
my favorite thing to do trust yourself
you are a lot more knowledgeable than
you think you are
I regret spending so much time
procrastinating and I know that this is
something so hard for most people to get
over but but I think like I wish I had
spent more time building really good
habits around not going on Facebook not
going on Twitter or not to be obsessed
with like all the social media stuff and
finding a better way to do the things
that end up giving me memories I look
back on fondly like I don't look back on
fondly with scrolling through my
facebook feed but I look back fondly on
like you know when I learned how to surf
or when I made my first video like do
these things that were active I wish I
did more of that than passive I could be
I could be famous
[Music]